[Musique]
c'est l'heure de l'invité politique
aujourd'hui je reçois nicolas bay le
député européen du rassemblement
national bonjour nicolas bay au jour
alors nous sommes ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté aujourd'hui par
contre il y avait un bon jour pascal je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
au groupe ebra des journaux de l'est de
la france
alors on va commencer par parler de la
sphère fillon une affaire relance et par
les propos de la procureure nationale
financière de l'époque
eliane houlette qui a affirmé avoir subi
des pressions de la part de sa
hiérarchie
le président de la république a demandé
au conseil supérieur de la magistrature
est bien de faire toute la lumière sur
cette affaire
est ce que cette affaire au final à
fausser l'élection présidentielle oui
c'est une affaire qui est extrêmement
grave en réalité puisqu'il y avait des
soupçons important depuis le début d'une
instrumentalisation de l'institution
judiciaire à des fins politiques et
c'est vrai que tout le monde avait été
troublé par la percussion réalité du
calendrier judiciaire sur le calendrier
politique la justice qui habituellement
si lente en france
en quelques jours eh bien elle avait
procédé aux perquisitions à la longue
quête à la mise en examen de françois
fillon et settat au delà de la caisse du
fond du sujet sur lequel je me
prononcerai pas eh bien on voit bien
qu'avec une volonté finalement
d'utiliser la justice pour empêcher
françois fillon d'être candidat ou en
tout cas d'être candidat dans de bonnes
conditions
donc il y avait une vraie manoeuvre
politique au moment de la création du
parti du parquet national financier
certain avait dit attention on voit bien
que ça peut être utilisé à des fins
politiques est évidemment nous avait dit
mais non pas du tout on voit bien qu'on
a été le parquet national financiers ça
n'est pas un outil judiciaire c'est
d'abord un outil politique et c'est
extrêmement grave parce que aujourd'hui
on fait on donne beaucoup de leçons
d'état de droit à tout un tas de pays à
la hongrie et la pologne je le vois au
parlement européen par contre en france
on a aujourd'hui une dérive très
inquiétante que l'utilisation de la
justice je dis pas que tous les
magistrats sont concernées y en a qui
font leur travail de manière serrée avec
sérieux à partialité etc mais on voit
bien qu'il ya une volonté d'utiliser la
justice pour essayer d'atteindre les
responsables politiques justement
faut-il en terminer avec ce parc est
rattaché un chancellerie ou
garde des sceaux et non mais uniquement
du juge indépendant oui il faut il faut
garantir l'indépendance de la justice et
ça passe par tout un tas de mesures pas
seulement d'ailleurs en essayant de
limiter la tutelle politique du sur le
parquet mais également dans le
recrutement des magistrats dans la
formation des magistrats
aujourd'hui on sait que par exemple
qu'il ya environ 25% des magistrats qui
votent pour le syndicat de la
magistrature aux élections
professionnelles
le syndicat de la magistrature ce n'est
pas contrairement à ce que son nom
indique simplement un syndicat qui
défend les intérêts des magistrats sur
le plan de leur activité professionnelle
c'est une structure politique politique
est politisée qui prend des positions
politiques qui appellent à voter par an
contre le rassemblement national
direction
est-ce que des juges carte et un
syndicat de la magistrature peuvent
faire leur travail avec indépendance
honnêteté impartialité lorsqu'il s'agit
par exemple de sujets politiques qui
concernent des responsables évidemment
pas et justement rassemblement national
est ce que vous vous vous sentez que
vous êtes victime d'une justice
politique
on en a un exemple pas plus tard que
cette semaine rappelons ne le parquet de
paris a fait appel de la relaxe
partielle du front national concernant
une affaire d'escroquerie pour la
campagne de 2012
alors je résume ça fait maintenant
quatre ou cinq ans qu'on explique que le
rassemblement national a commis une
escroquerie avec la fée a dit des kits
de campagne voilà il s'avère que la
justice nous dit que l'équipe de
campagne finalement était parfaitement
régulier ya aucune condamnation qui
prend sur l'équipe de campagne et où il
ya simplement une décision de justice
qui nous est défavorable c'est vrai sur
la question des intérêts d'emprunt je
veux pas rentrer dans les détails trop
techniques mais la décision de justice
vient en flagrante contradiction avec
toutes la jurisprudence et les décisions
prises par la commission nationale des
comptes de campagne qui nous autorise t
administrative indépendante qui venus
d'ailleurs rappelé au moment du procès à
l'audience que le le système des
intérêts d'emprunt qui était mis en
place était parfaitement conforme qu'il
avait été validée qu'il serait à nouveau
aujourd'hui si des comptes de campagne
était présenté donc il ya un litige
juridique qui perdure sur ce point là
mais finalement c'est une décision de
justice qui nous donnent largement
raison et qui nous blanchi de cette
accusation d' escroquerie sur l'équipe
de campagne bon le parquet a été
indigents dans son argumentation
juridique au moment du procès ya
quelques mois indigent incapables
d'avancer la moindre argumentation
juridique incapable d'art
comptable voilà et malgré tout eh bien
il fait un appel général de ce jugement
alors que voilà ce jugement est
simplement ils confirment le fait qu'il
n'y a pas eu d'escroquerie sur l'équipe
de campagne
donc on voit bien qu'ils une
instrumentalisation et quel est
l'objectif derrière c'est évidemment
d'avoir un procès en appel qui
interviendra dans quelques mois fin 2021
peut-être début 2022 c'est à dire là
encore sans doute une volonté de
percuter le calendrier électoral voilà
donc on voit bien que
l'instrumentalisant la justice c'est
quelque chose de très concret de
récurrents eh bien il faut y mettre fin
alors autre actualité judiciaire elle
concerne les violences à dijon de la
semaine dernière puisque quatre membres
de la communauté de tchétchènes ont été
mises en examen trois sont actuellement
en détention provisoire sur ce point la
justice réagi assez vite selon vous
l'état était défaillant à tous les
étages
à dijon on a des arbres et des haies des
affrontements d'une extrême gravité
entre des des bandes ethniques des
bandes communautaire qui qui règlent
leurs comptes avec des armes pas
seulement des armes à feu avec des armes
de guerre avec des fusils d'assaut des
fusils automatiques de type kalashnikov
bon l'état a et les hiérarchies
politique
christophe castaner ont été absents
incapable d'apporter une réponse à la
hauteur
quasiment aucune interpellation et
ratissage du secteur par les forces de
l'ordre très tardif aujourd'hui a
toujours des armes plein les caf plein
les appartements plein les voitures qui
circulent dans ces quartiers c'est vrai
dit jean mehal également à nice où il ya
eu des événements analogues où
s'affrontaient également des bandes de
madaba des bandes de tchétchènes voilà
tout ça est très inquiétant est le plus
grave c'est que c'est même pas l'état
qui ensuite parvient à un retour au
calme
c'est sous l'égide de l'imam dans la
mosquée radicale du secteur qui est tenu
par l'une par l'uejf donc les frères
musulmans que une sorte de l'armistice
est conclu entre les bandes rivales
voilà donc on voit bien que dans ces
quartiers là non seulement la loi de la
république ne s'applique pas mais en
réalité ça va au delà c'est un autre
ordre qu est mis en place
c'est un autre hors politico religieuses
qui se substituent aux lois de la
république tweete toutes les semaines il
y en a eu encore à nantes il ya des
manifestations contre les violences
policières de la part
d'une partie de la population cette
partie la brochure perdu confiance à la
police républicaine comment la restaurer
non mais je comptais une accusation
contre la police qui est insupportable
en réalité on a les phénomènes de
violence de ce qu'on appelle les
violences policières sont des phénomènes
qui sont extrêmement rares les cas
litigieux sont rares d'ailleurs on parle
de la sphère adama traoré ça date d'il
ya quatre ans on nous a parlé ces
derniers jours de la sphère de la mine
zhang
ça date d'il ya 13 ans donc je dis pas
que syndicats tous les liens non je dis
je dis pas que ça ne peut pas arriver
mais je pense que c'est des phénomènes
qui restent marginaux qui restera bon en
revanche il ya des faits très concret en
vingt mille policiers et gendarmes
blessés dans l'exercice de la fonction
donc les violences contre les policiers
sont en volume
infiniment supérieur sans aucune sans
comparaison possible avec des violences
qui serait attribuée à aux forces de
l'ordre
j'ajoute qui a eu 59 policiers qui se
sont suicidés 20 policiers qui sont
morts en service l'année dernière donc
qu'on arrête d'accuser la police de tout
et n'importe quoi
on voit qu'il ya une sorte de
convergence des luttes aujourd'hui entre
l'extrême gauche politiques syndicales
associatives on a vu la résurgence
d'associations dont on pensait qu'ils
avaient disparu les associés l'un des
années 80 la ss racisme le mrap etc
qu'ils se joignaient à des gens qui ont
fait des manifestations à caractère
racial c'est utile à une posture
racialiste et il exprime la haine de la
france la haine de la police
et leur volonté de créer le chaos dans
le pays en attaquant les forces de
l'ordre qui je le rappelle font un
travail très difficile dans des
conditions matérielles difficiles en
sous-effectif et avec souvent une une
hiérarchie défaillante à commencer par
le ministre intérieur castaner qui les
vit dans ce monde pas du tout à la
hauteur et ce qu'ils répondent aux mails
et ce policier est ce qu'il a apaisé la
situation avec les policiers non je
pense qu'il a rien apaisé du doubs tout
le monde fait le constat très simple que
il est pas du tout fait pour être miss
d'intérieur on savait depuis le début
aujourd'hui ça devient une évidence
en quelques jours sous la pression de
militants gauchistes
il a lâché la police il explique que la
police que si un soupçon de racisme et
bien à ce moment immédiatement le
policier doit être un billet
et c'est à dire en clair il n'a pas le
droit à la présomption d'innocence la
parole du voyou compte plus que celle du
gardien de la paix c'est d'une extrême
gravité
ensuite il ad il veut désarmer la police
il il ya des techniques d'interpellation
qui ont fait leurs preuves utilisées
depuis des années des années qu'on en
discute et qu'elles soient évalués c'est
normal mais là ils veulent a supprimé
unilatéralement du jour au lendemain
sans la remplacer par aucune disposition
donc on a des gens qui tirent à la
kalachnikov
on en parlait il ya quelques instants et
les policiers n'a même pas le droit de
les attraper par le couple pour les
neutraliser enfin pour les interpeller
on voit bien que on a un ministre de
l'intérieur qui n'est pas là pour faire
respecter la loi et l'ordre
c'est sa mission c'est sa fonction il
n'est pas là il est même incapable de
diriger protéger défendre les forces de
l'ordre il est là que pour les
culpabiliser aux côtés de ses mythes des
militants gauchistes
vous avez parlé de soupçons de racisme
faut-il en france introduire des
statistiques ethniques pour pouvoir
enfin vérifier s'il ya du racisme signal
voici ce qu elles sont utilisées par
certains chercheurs notamment par
l'insee pour montrer les discriminations
dans l'accès au logement
oui elle existe d'ailleurs beaucoup de
pays on voit bien que cette
revendication elle est exprimée par
certains qui voudraient à cette occasion
établir qui auraient des discriminations
à l'embauché pour l'accès au logement
etc
moi ce que je ne crois pas du tout je
pense pas du tout que les
discriminations je dis pas non mais je
dis pas ça veut pas dire qu'il peut pas
y avoir des fautes individuelles mais je
crois pas qu'il ya de discrimination
raciale massives en france je pense que
la france est tout sauf un pays raciste
bon nous on n'a jamais été très
favorable à ces l'idée de statistiques
ethniques mais moi je dis à ceux qui
sont qui sont favorables qui dès qu'ils
feraient bien de faire très attention
parce qu'arrêter si on fait des
statistiques ethniques comme c'est le
cas aux états unis par exemple eh bien
il a des statistiques ethniques aussi
sur les allocataires des deux qui
bénéficient des dettes sociales sur la
délinquance et sur la criminalité et je
pense que ça va aller exactement l
inverse de ce que ce qu'ils veulent
comme audi a essayé de trouver alors on
va parler maintenant nicolas bay
d'écologie un sujet qui peut également
ravivé certaine tension la convention
citoyenne pour le climat a publié ses
propositions faites au gouvernement avec
parmi les propositions des citoyens
notamment la limitation à 110 km/heure
de la vitesse sur les autoroutes la
rénovation thermique obligatoire pour
les bâtiments
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
certaines de ces pros
position le sentiment que ça donne c'est
qu'il ya 150 personnes au départ elles
sont tirées au sort leur est utile sont
sélectionnés sur un panel qui de
volontaires ensuite il ya ceux qui
restent qui est impliqué et qui parle au
nom de la convention donc on voit qu'il
ya une démarche de plus en plus
politique idéologique et du coup de
moins en moins représentative la vérité
c'est que si on avait pris le conseil
national des verts on aurait obtenu à
peu près les mêmes le même résultat et
les mêmes propositions certaines
honnêtement sont très caricatural et pas
très sérieuse je pense par exemple à la
semaine de quatre jours et 28 heures
travaillées elle était proposé avec
insistance
honnêtement voir le président de la
république qui dit pourquoi pas un
référendum
par exemple sur la rénovation thermique
ou la performance d'isolation des
bâtiments
ça fait quand même sourire parce que je
pense que c'est un sujet de consensus et
pas besoin de faire f un homme là dessus
on dénie aux français la possibilité
d'un référendum sur des sujets
fondamentaux
la dernière fois qu'on a interrogé les
français par référendum c'était il ya 15
ans et le vote a été piétinée d'ailleurs
sur la surélever le traité
constitutionnel européen soit l'union
européenne on ne demande pas leur avis
aux français sur l'immigration on
demande pas leur avis aux français sur
les protections économique ont fini avec
la logique du bel échange mondialisé ça
doit intéresser la convention sur le
climat
on ne demande pas leur avis aux français
et dans le même temps on va on voudrait
nous vendre un petit qcm sur deux trois
dispositions techniques ou pour
certaines très idéologique
voilà ça me some honnêtement pas à la
hauteur c'est un travail trop
idéologique
je pense que l'écologie est un sujet
fondamental la défense de notre
environnement c'est un sujet fondamental
est la première chose à faire
aujourd'hui c'est de rompre avec les
grands dogmes qui ont dominé la
structuration de notre économie
ces dernières décennies à commencer par
ce dogme du libre échange total voilà si
on veut protéger si on veut protéger
notre notre notre écosystème notre
environnement et bien arrêtons de
fabriquer en chine des produits
manufacturés à destination du marché
européen avec à chaque fois des
marchandises qui font des mythes et des
milliers de kilomètres sur les mers et
qui polluent avec des navires des
supertankers qui polluent plus que des
millions de voitures individuelles et
justement on va parler du marché
européen je rappelle que vous êtes
député européen les chefs d'état de
l'union européenne sont en train de
discuter du fameux plan de relance de
750 milliards d'euros pour relancer
l'économie européenne
est ce que l'europe a été au rendez vous
sur cette crise alors d'abord l'union
européenne n'a pas été les institutions
européennes n'ont pas été au rendez vous
de la crise sanitaire
incapable de coordonner l'action des
états membres est incapable
d'anticipation alors qu'elle disposait
d'outils extrêmement performant
notamment un centre de de prévention des
maladies et aider des épidémies
incapable de relayer les préconisations
auprès des états membres dont qu'elle a
été défaillante totalement les
institutions européennes défaillante sur
la crise sanitaire elle même elle essaie
de se rattraper aujourd'hui avec des
chiffres qui sont spectaculaires mais
presque vertigineux d'emilie des
milliers de milliards d'euros ont été au
total et on évoque actuellement cette
tranche de 750 milliards on a été
rapporté à l'échelle d'un pays c'est pas
des somme si importante puisque je
rappelle que c'est les chiffres qui
portent sur les 27 pays de l'union
européenne vont ensuite la question
c'est de savoir quelle est la plus value
européenne est ce qu on a une vraie un
vrai avantage à ce que ce dispositif
d'aidés directes et de prêts soient
organisées à l'échelle continentale
et moi je ne crois pas parce qu'en
réalité on finalement on tourne toujours
dans les mêmes travers
en europe il ya neuf pays contributeurs
nets sur 27
donc à un moment donné enfin on fera
toujours nous la france comme mais comme
un certain nombre d'autres partis de
ceux qui payent plus qu'ils ne reçoivent
et donc ces aides européennes
elles vont être décidée par la
commission européenne les critères
d'attribution seront décidées à
bruxelles alors que si on avait une
enveloppe qui est comme on dit emprunter
directement en france par l'état est
bien l'état pour a dit disposer beaucoup
plus librement avec plus d'agilité de
cet argent et la manière dont il est
utilisé et puis on sait très bien ce qui
va se passer derrière c'est que parce
que l onu en réalité on va augmenter
notre dette de manière considérable eh
bien ça va être la justification à une
fiscalité européenne un impôt européen
thierry breton explique m nous on n'est
pas content par exemple une taxe carbone
qu'il permettrait de faire des droits de
douane déguisé en quelque sorte et
d'éviter la concurrence déloyale de pays
qui qui qui font venir de voilà deux des
marchandises chez nous de l'autre bout
du monde
en respectant aucune norme ni sociale ni
sanitaire ni environnementale
mais là on sait très bien qu'on va avoir
une fiscalité européenne
adm qui va être une espèce de couche
supplémentaire dans le mille feuilles
dans une feuille fiscal alors qu'on a
déjà en france par exemple
47 % de notre pib en prélèvements
obligatoires ce qui fait de la france un
des pays les plus taxés au monde
oui parlons un peu du rassemblement
national
robert ménard qui votre allié le maire
de béziers a dit marine le pen ce n'est
pas la bonne candidate pour 2022 aura
déjà candidate
que lui répondez vous c'est pas la
première fois qu'il dit ça je vais pas
rentrer dans une polémique avec robert
ménard mais on voit bien que ce que je
déplore dans son attitude c'est que
c'est on n'est pas dans la dans la
critique constructive
on est dans la critique pour la critique
et j'entends des repas de propositions
alternatives de sa part moi je crois que
marine le pen aujourd'hui elle est la
présidente du rassemblement national
qu'est la force politique principal et
peut-être même la seule vraie force
d'opposition face à emmanuel macron et à
son gouvernement est donc évidemment il
le pen se trouve être en situation
aujourd'hui d'être la candidate la plus
sérieuse la plus crédible et
rassembleuse pour 2022 même si 2022
c'est encore loin
c'est dans deux ans on a des échéances
électorales importantes avant dimanche
prochain et surtout en 2021 et donc il
faut sauter les haies les unes après les
autres mais mais ce que je crois c'est
que notre objectif au rassemblement
national c'est évidemment de dell à agir
bien sûr de rassembler au delà de notre
seul parti on n'est pas dans une
démarche partisane on n'est pas dans une
démarche monolithique et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs aux élections européennes on
a accueilli sur nos listes et moi je
travaille maintenant au sein de notre
groupe avec des députés européens comme
jean paul garraud comme thierry mariani
qui viennent des républicains et qui en
réalité se sont inscrits dans une
démarche de rassemblement à nos côtés
sans d'ailleurs laissé sciemment leur
carte du rassemblement national
alors on va évoquer la prochaine est
électoral avec ce second tour des
élections municipales dimanche prochain
d'abord si on regarde les chiffres pour
le rassemblement national concernant
notamment les communes de dix mille
habitants en 2014
le rn avait qualifié 86% de ses listes
au second tour que 52% de des listes
d'url au second tour sont qualifiés en
2020 il ya eu une sorte d'effondrement
il ya eu un effondrement d'abord de la
participation ça vous a pas échappé le
15 mars dernier et sans doute que nous
avons été plus touchés que les autres
partis politiques par ce phénomène parce
qu'on
l'électorat populaire et les enquêtes
d'opinion montrent que l'électorat
populaire a été plus abstentionniste
encore que là est des français mais
quand on a 20 points défendre de moins
de participation par rapport au scrutin
de référence ici à 2014
évidemment ça a été un peu la sincérité
du scrutin parce que évidemment le la
crise sanitaire a comme andy a eu un
impact direct
quand vous êtes le premier ministre la
veille du scrutin a dit aux gens à
rester chez vous c'est compliqué ensuite
de la dia d'aller voter et de se
mobiliser
bon mais pour autant nos mères nos
villes acquises en 2014 nos maires ont
été élus pour la plupart dès le premier
tour et parfois très brillamment avec
des résultats importants ça valide la
qualité de la gestion du rassemblement
national dans ces villes et puis pour
dimanche prochain
il ya des villes qui peuvent être gagnés
je pense à perpignan avec louis aliot
mais je pense à des plus petites
communes comme moi ça comme vauvert
comme morières les avignon où nous
sommes en situation de l'emporter avec
des résultats plus de 40 +2 45% des voix
au premier tour et moi ce que je
voudrais dire aux électeurs pour son
second tour c'est que beaucoup de maires
ont essayé de faire un peu oublier la
bilan en distribuant des masques pendant
deux mois ils l'ont fait l'argent public
ils l'ont fait et c'est normal il n'y a
rien d'extraordinaire mais maintenant il
faut en revenir à la démocratie c'est le
déconfinement démocratique en quelque
sorte
dimanche prochain et donc il faut voter
en fonction des vrais enjeux municipaux
il ya des mères qui ont fait du
communautarisme qui en fait du
gaspillage d'argent public qui ont une
fille ski qui ont mis en oeuvre une
fiscalité beaucoup trop élevés qui ont
laissé la sécurité frappé durement la
territoire c'est là dessus qu'ils
doivent être jugés et qui devait
éventuellement sanctionné par les yoles
et puis j'ajouterai que même quand on
n'est pas en situation de gagner avoir
des élus du rassemblement national c'est
avoir des lanceurs dallaire dans le
conseil municipal des gens qui sont là
pour dire la vérité et qui évite aussi
que les décisions soient prises dans une
certaine opacité
ce qui caractérise trop souvent la
gestion des collectivités locales oui
donc - donnant il y aura les élections
régionales en principe emmanuel macron
songerait un report pour vous c'est un
scrutin qui compte beaucoup
quelle est votre position là dessus
égouttez la démocratie ce n'est pas
facultatif et on ne dispose pas c'est ce
qu' elle m'apprend à l'air de croire on
ne dispose pas librement de la date du
scrutin les conseillers régionaux élus
en 2015 si l'on est élu pour cinq ans on
a tu de la loi des diffusions du code
électoral a le mandat
de cinq ans alors s'il y avait une
raison objective et qu'il fallait
apporter pour quelques mois
comme si déjà ils enverraient l'once
économique non mais ça c'est pas une
simple panne à raison suffisante
il peut arriver qu'on a un télescopage
de plusieurs élections la même année et
dont on reporte de quelques mois l'un
des scrutins
ça peut s'expliquer et d'ailleurs il
faut une loi pour ça mais on va pas
reporter le scrutin de deux ans puisque
ça semble être le projet pour convenance
personnelle parce que là c'est de ça
dont il s'agit
alors emmanuel macron voudrais faire une
discussion de marchands de tapis avec
les présidents de région et certains
d'entre eux ont l'air d'être très tout à
fait favorable je pense à un os muselier
en paca en normandie avec morin tout ça
dans le dos des électeurs
tout ça dans l'opacité totale avec des
transferts de gros sous entre l'état et
les régions
c'est évidemment inacceptable c'est aux
électeurs de décider et de donner un
mandat et quand les électeurs confié un
mandat à des élus et bien ce mandat il
est subordonné à une durée voilà donc
quand on est élu pour cinq ans n'est pas
élus pour six ans pour cette recette nos
objectifs presque une obligation de
gagner une ou deux régions à pitre c'est
pas une obligation mais c'est sans doute
une possibilité on a montré notre
capacité à gérer à bien gérer des
collectivités locales importantes des
municipalités parfois de taille
importante je pense que nous pouvons
gagner des régions et montrait qu' une
autre gestion est possible de nos
régions
bien sûr et ce sera une étape
supplémentaire avant 2022 vous serez
candidat pour la région normandie
beaucouzé c'est un peu tôt pour le dire
mais oui bien sûr moi je ne suis pas dit
dans notre groupe au conseil régional
c'est mon implantation locale qu'elle je
suis très attaché à normandie bien sûr
et donc je serai présent dans cette
bataille
merci beaucoup nicolas bay d'avoir été à
notre invité ce matin